salut
je vais bien merci merci de m'avoir rendu visite
rôle des nouvelles
technologies dans nos vies
l'utilité ratée de ces objets
symbolise la façon dont l'IA a le
potentiel de devenir problématique
et j'espère que mon travail aboutira à une discussion
autour de ces sujets
[Musique]
Ada a pu entrer dans l'histoire en tant que
premier robot à  être capable de concevoir pour
concevoir des articles ménagers
[Musique]
Je ne pense pas que la réglementation va
rattraper le fait que la
technologie évolue si rapidement, mais nous
avons besoin de responsabilité et nous devons
être en mesure de peut-être tester ces choses le
algorithmes avec un petit groupe de personnes,
nous voulons un monde sûr, nous voulons le bénéfice, il y a des
points négatifs, nous devons donc y réfléchir,
alors ralentissez-le pour y penser
afin que nous puissions voir que l'
effet domino potentiel est vraiment important
[Musique]
merci